SPEAKER: Meet Cloud
Functions, a faster way
to build in the cloud.
You focus on writing your
code, and Cloud Functions
makes sure your application runs
resiliently, cost effectively,
and at planet-scale,
allowing you to move
faster than ever before.
Events are happening all
the time in your system,
like file uploads
to Cloud Storage,
changes to database records,
requests to HTTP endpoints,
and more.
You write code that runs in
response to those events,
and Cloud Functions runs it
and automatically manages
underlying
infrastructure for you.
And you only pay while
your code is running.
Whether you're
building applications
for the enterprise, e-commerce,
consumers, or anyone else,
the Cloud Functions
makes it easy.
It connects and extends your
cloud services with code
so that you can treat
them as building blocks,
move fast, and adjust
as your needs change.
With Cloud Functions, you can
apply artificial intelligence
when new data shows
up in your system.
It only takes a
few lines of code
to understand what's inside
your images, video, or text.
Bring IoT device data
into your application
and analyze it as it arrives.
Use big data
analytics and machine
learning in your
Google Assistant app
to build engaging conversational
experiences for your users.
Or extend your application
using the broad ecosystem
of third-party
services and APIs.
No matter what you're
building, with Cloud Functions,
you can innovate faster,
focus on what really matters,
and build great
applications for your users.
The possibilities are
endless with code.
Visit cloud.google.com/functions
and go build something amazing
today.